so right now economists are divided
about 50% believe that in the next 12
months there's going to be a recession
50% believe it'll be avoided polls
indicate that 69% of us consumers expect
a recession in 12 months and 84% of CEOs
believe that's going to happen and some
people think there's positive indicators
because GDP is growing but when you look
at Rising interest rates real estate
market when you look at the long pause
the Federal Reserve is going to do maybe
raise and student loan payments that
just kicked in as well as the dollar not
going as far the economy is a major
question mark and you've been in the
game a long time I value your
perspective I'm just curious what's your
mindset how are you approaching this
what are maybe some of your predictions
maybe regardless of what happens what
are you personally doing in response to
the environment we're going into well
it's interesting question and I it is
because it matters are you an employee
or are you an
entrepreneur so which assumption would
you like me to take well I'd like you to
maybe hit both of them because yeah tell
us the two scenarios if you're an
employee it's going to be
disaster between
technology uh changing wiping out jobs
uh more performance-based pay not wages
anymore more and more companies are
going to pay only for performance not
just salespeople but everybody you're
not going to be able to hide inside of
corporate structures there's all kinds
of things happening inside of commercial
real estate everything else
all across that landscape things are
just changing dramatically one of the
things the pandemic did is it is it
shrunk a maybe a 10-year transition
window into three years our habits have
changed you take a look at what happened
to movie theaters as an example it used
to be a regular normal thing now when
was the last time you went to a movie
theater to actually see a movie it's got
to be something special and there isn't
that much special that your big screen
TV or maybe you upgrade that TV during
the pandemic to be able to watch is not
a a close um comparable to that
experience so you you go to an AMC
theater right now and it's kind of sad
you know it's like they're trying to
like please come back it's it's over
it's over people have changed now
they're they're watching things on their
tablets and on their on their laptops
and on their desktops and screencasting
from their phone up to a screen on their
wall I have a huge screen TV at my house
we don't want to go to the movie theater
we're fine uh where we are so just hurry
up and and release that movie and put it
on Amazon Prime or wherever I can watch
it and that's where I'm going to watch
it so same thing's going to happen
across all employee sectors in my
opinion it's going to get squeezed
downsizing uh unemployment is going to
go up lots of challenges now take the
other side the entrepreneur side guess
what it doesn't
matter economic boom or Bust it doesn't
matter it never has for an
entrepreneur you people every election
cycle people like this one this one if
the other guy gets in it's the end of
the world for sure that's that's been
said every election for my entire
lifetime and for for some employees
maybe that's true but for entrepreneurs
it never is because entrepreneurs adapt
and entrepreneurs look at every obstacle
as an opportunity and entrepreneurs
actually in the of recession that's
where most success stories are created
is entrepreneurs step in during those
periods of time go back and and reverse
engineer all the big companies that you
can think of and find out when they
started you're going to find them
starting in pretty difficult times so
entrepreneurs look for opportunity when
other people are frozen in fear they
adapt and they pivot while other people
are slow to change I'll tell you this I
think the next 18 months to three years
is going to be A Tale of Two Cities
literally literally uh for some it's
going to be the best of times they're
going to find opportunity pivot adapt
adjust innovate and for some it's going
to be the worst of times it's going to
be disaster and they're going to have
lots of stuff that they can blame it on
they're going to blame it on whoever got
in the White House they're going to
blame it on global economics they blame
it on the FED uh blame it on interest
rates blame it on debt they blame it on
a million things but entrepreneurs just
say that's fine you guys stay over there
all confused and blaming each other I'm
going to go innovate over here and I'll
create
A Better Business out of it you know so
I've always kind of grinned at the you
know what are you going to do I'm going
to adapt that's what I'm going to do you
know if the Republicans get in I'll
adapt if Democrats get in it's not the
end of the world I'll adapt and that's
what I've been doing my whole life
there's probably two types of people
listening to this uh one group got super
fired up they already have the
entrepreneur mentality they maybe were
looking ahead with some trepidation but
you just let that fire again it's like
that's that's right it's A Tale of Two
Cities and I know which Camp I'm going
to be in there's others though that you
know we speak to YouTube creators
content creators people stepping in the
Creator economy business owners that are
trying to get more leads and clients and
sales with content and then maybe a
third group of those that are looking
for a side hustle those that are
full-time right now you're like
employees are going to get squeezed you
got to be thinking about creating extra
streams of Revenue what do you think it
takes to make that transition maybe be
clearer there are those who say okay
well it's going to be good for
entrepreneurs but I'm not an
entrepreneur is there an opportunity for
anybody to become one sure but it takes
a bit of of reprogramming your
mind one of my mentors his name is Sam
georgees he um was Tony Robbins CEO for
22 years incredible guy retired lives
here in Las Vegas he says there are two
kinds of people one are coin operated
and the other ones are entrepreneurs and
coin operated you know put in put in a
coin you get a result you know and
they're they're they're exchanging their
time for money or or an effort or a
result for money and entrepreneurs are
willing to take bigger risk and and do
what they need to do so most people have
been trained to think like an employee
since they were two years old do as
you're told or there's going to be
consequences brush your teeth there's
going to be consequences stop hitting
your sister you know finish your
vegetables go to bed or there's going to
be consequences and then it repeats in
school you know study for the test that
there's going to be consequences you
don't pass this grade there's going to
be consequences that gets built in Don't
Be Tardy too many days or there's going
to be consequences you get detention
whatever you get written up in your
permanent record which I've never seen
by the way they threatened it so many
times when I went to school and then
when you get out of school you get a job
and in that job you are consequen driven
as well show up on time and there's
consequences here's all long lunches
there's consequences you know make sure
you perform good enough or you know
there's going to be consequences there
could be rewards too
uh so we've been trained to think like
employees and it's exactly opposite of
how entrepreneurs think so
employees when I when I speak around the
world and I ask people what comes to
mind when I say the word
work and guess what I get pain
obligation traffic
drudgery um uncomfortable
obligation that's the list yeah and
because of that and because they've been
trained as an employee to
work so so they can rest the rest is the
objective the retirement is the
objective the weekend is the objective
right to get away from all this stuff is
the objective so
entrepreneurs look at work completely
different work is Passion work is
creation work is purpose work work is
Mission um work is
contribution you know so why would you
want to get away from that yep so the
employee minded people think the
entrepreneurs are crazy people because
they rest just long enough to work while
the employees are working just long
enough to
rest so most entrepreneurs don't can't
even fathom I can't even fathom
retirement sure I can I can fathom
lifestyle doing it my way but I can't
fathom like wanting to get away from
this so that's just one example there's
a million that I could give you
entrepreneurs think on one side of the
coin and employees think on the other
side of the coin so whether it's work or
investment or sacrifice or time you know
uh an employee for example is willing to
give you about two weeks and if if
within two weeks you don't get paid
they're gone yeah but an entrepreneur is
willing to be underpaid for a long
period of time yeah yes fairly paid for
a very short period of time and then
overpaid for a long period of time
they're willing to trade under for over
and that's different right um than what
people that this is unfair you're taking
advantage of me I'm putting in all this
work I'm not getting any results or
you're working for yourself you know
this is stupid why am I doing this I'm
getting paid $1 an hour for the amount
of time that I'm putting into growing my
YouTube channel or or growing my
business this is dumb this is this
doesn't even make any sense but you got
to put in that price and you're willing
to invest your time where employees are
like nope if I don't get a a certain
amount per hour y not doing it you know
same thing with the support
entrepreneurs create support everybody
else is looking for support you know
they create their own support and I
could go on and on and on but you really
have to learn how to think like an
entrepreneur and you can reprogram your
mind because I think we were all born
with creation and contribution and
Mission and passion and all of that
stuff in us and it was beaten into US
programmed into us to do as we're told
or there's going to be consequences if
you enjoyed this podcast and are ready
for some deep dive YouTube strategy just
go to think masterclass.com to get
access to my 1hour OnDemand YouTube
strategy class you'll be looking over my
shoulder as I share my best tips and you
can watch it on Demand right now at
think masterclass.com